Madame Tussauds Wax Museum in London has
already removed the harry and megan wax
figures from the royal family display
took him out they're gone yes yes now I
was curious what they did with Harry and
Megan's wax figures so I found the
museum employee who's temporarily
storing them he's here with us via
satellite all the way from London please
welcome Oliver gray Conan she liked it
to be here thank you
Thank You Oliver you have generously
offered to keep the wax figures of Harry
and Megan safe while the royal family
drama gets worked out yeah that's
correct and if I may I would just like
to say that I'm definitely not using the
wax figures for sex stuff just to clear
that up yeah I didn't I didn't say or
suggest anything like that no no of
course not but you were thinking it
no I really wasn't thinking it at all I
was not thinking pretty sure we were all
thinking it yeah I was thinking okay
well that's not the point
Oliver where are the figures wax figures
now ah they are in a loving home Conan
and I treat them better than the museum
ever did they didn't appreciate
Megan's soft hands or Harry's supple
lips oh you know Oliver now I am
starting to think it's possible you're
using for sex stuff I really am told you
you were thinking it I'm afraid to ask
what condition are the figures currently
in what position are they in oh I'm not
sure what it's called he's on his back
she's no no no no I didn't say position
what condition are they in Tory yeah
yeah I know they're in good condition a
little worse for the wear since I stick
him in me hot tub that was a mistake
wait what happened well they're about a
foot shorter now which actually works
perfectly for what I have planned you
know Oliver we just see the wax figures
can we see them not right now they're
sleeping wax figures don't sleep oh yeah
you're right actually we don't do too
much sleep you know
it is clear sir that you're a creep I'm
gonna contact the wax museum to let them
know yeah they know I'm a creep who else
do you think wants to the wax museum all
right I'm saying goodbye now Oliver all
right you Lou thanks for having me
[Applause]